rewrite y is equal to 2/3 x plus 4/7 in
standard form the equation must be
simplified
which means all numbers must be integers
that do not share a common factor other
than one alright we'll worry about this
second part in a little bit let's see if
we can rewrite this so it's y equals
two-thirds X plus 4/7 let me get my
scratch pad out so it's y is equal to
two-thirds X plus 4/7 so the way that
it's written right now this is
slope-intercept form it's written in the
form it's written in the form Y is equal
to MX plus B where m in this case is 2/3
and B is four sevens it's very easy to
figure out what the slope and what the
y-intercept is from this equation but we
want to write this in standard form
which would be the form ax plus B Y is
equal to C and that extra that extra
text they were saying the equation must
be simplified which means all numbers
must be integers that do not share a
common factor other than one that just
means that a B and C the in the standard
form they want need to be integers and
they want them to not have any common
factors so if we got it to the point of
say 4 X plus 2y is equal to is equal to
well these this number this number and
this number are all divisible by two
they all have the common factor of two
so we would want to simplify it more
divide them all by 2 and then you would
get to see divide this by 2 you get 2x
divide this by 2 you get plus y is equal
to 5 so this is the form that they're
asking for and probably because it's
just easier for the site to know that
this is the right answer because there's
obviously a bunch of forms in this way
so let's see if we can let's see if we
can do that let's see if we can write it
in standard form in standard form so the
first thing I would want to do is well
there's a bunch of ways that you could
approach it the first thing you could
try to do is well let's get rid of all
of these let's get rid of all of these
fractions and the best way to multiply
rid of the fractions is to multiply by 3
and 2 x 7 if you
by three you get rid of this fraction
you multiply by seven you get rid of
this fraction so if you multiply by
three and you multiply by seven let me
just rewrite it over here so actually
I'll show a couple of ways that we could
do this so if you multiply so one way to
do it so we start with y is equal to
two-thirds X plus 4/7 so if I multiply
this side by three and I multiply by
seven I have to do that to this side as
well so this is going to be x 3 and x
seven so the left-hand side becomes 21 y
21 y 3 x 7 of course is 21 we just
figured that out we would distribute the
21 21 times two-thirds well see 21
divided by 3 is 7 times 2 is 14 so it's
going to be 14x and then 21 divided by 7
is 3 times 4 is 12 so just like that I
was able to get rid of the fractions and
now let's try to get I want to get all
of the I want to get the all the X's and
Y's on one side so I want to get this
14x onto the left side so let's see if I
can do that so I'm going to do that by
it to get rid of this I would want to
subtract 14x I can't just do it on the
right hand side I have to do it on the
left hand side as well so I want to
subtract 14x and then what am I left
with
give myself a little bit more space so
on the left hand side I have negative
14x negative 14x plus 21y plus plus 21y
is equal to see I subtracted 14x to get
rid of this and then I have just as
equal to 12 now let's see do these am I
done
do these share any any is do 14 21 and
12 share any common factors let's see 14
is divisible by 2 and 7 21 is divisible
by 3 and 7 12 is divided divisible by 2
6 3 4 but all of these aren't divisible
by the same number 14 let's see 14
divisible by 2 so is 12 but 21 isn't 14
is divisible by 7 so is 21 but 12 isn't
and yep so and 21 and 12 or divisible by
3 but 14 is it so I think this is about
as simplified as I could get if there
was a common factor for all three of
these numbers then I would divide all of
them the way I did in that in that
previous example but that's not the case
right over here so it's negative 14x
plus 21y is equal to 12 so let me see if
I can remember that and type that in so
it is it is negative 14x plus 21y is
equal to is equal to 12 let's see if I
got it right it worked out